du kommst du was
hallo mein name ist so kann herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video von mir habe vor einer woche ein
video hochgeladen in dem ich auf einer
website mit euch video gechattet habe
alles irgendwie wegdrücken
ja und das machen wir heute wieder der
schon krass oder denker der ist megageil
nachdem verbindung ist hier wie immer
richtig gut
du hast kein mikro
der scheiße antworte einfach mit deinen
händen wie alt bist du bist du ein junge
oder ein mädchen
ach weißt du nicht geschrieben kannst du
mich grüßen heißt jan jan schöne grüße
ja
hallo bist du echt genug
neben ich nicht
er war weg gemacht
es geht bei mir auch was machst du
gerade so ich auch tatsächlich das ist
gut wenn menschen das machen lass mich
raten wo du herkommst stuttgart augsburg
er der erste fc köln spielt nächste
woche gegen augsburg da kannst du lachen
spiel zu pokémon boa jetzt ist gerade
erschienen guck mal gucken ob zu fragen
kann sind fangen kannst du hast du props
vor mir
okay es war schon mal nicht so gut wie
man besten meister bei den hyper war
okay erstens wir nichts das ist wird
eines der besten pokémon die es gibt
gott kann ich meine mutter mich etwas
fragen
kosten also um ein geschäft machen
das ist was ist wirklich schlimmer
fragen wollte ja wenn ihr möchtet
betrifft fast komplett aus
hi
schön schöner farbverlauf hi
nach schöner politik
[Musik]
wie geht's dir blendend ich war gestern
noch 39 innerhalb grad fieber hatte ich
und lag im bett aber jetzt geht es mir
gut weil ich bat nicht getroffen hier
kannst du diener & diener und tobias
soll dich grüßen ok als schöne grüße an
laser luca auf instagram ich muss fast
kotzen fällig
wichtig ist jetzt sehen sie dass ich das
kotzen
die sah ja interessant ja nein ja doch
noch was waren so die komischsten leute
die du bisher heute gesehen hast mich
ich habe er hat so schön cool vielleicht
treffe ich ja noch und kann man aus der
schweiz
das ist so krass wirklich die meisten
leute die ich treffe kommen entweder
irgendwie aus süddeutschland oder direkt
österreich oder schweiz
ja das gibt es halt ja dass der große
ich habe es irgendwie den ersten part
omega habe ich gemacht da war ich
irgendwie 45 minuten insgesamt auf der
plattform und jetzt hier im zweiten fall
bin ich jetzt auch schon seit einer
halben stunde auf der plattform und es
kann noch keiner aus norddeutschland
doch überhaupt niemand alle jäger aus
süddeutschland österreich oder der
schweiz ich sehe auch bei meinem
instagram einfach die meisten leute die
mich auf install abonniert haben kommen
aus wien sag mal auf italienisch
abonniert alle kräfte
du kannst auch reden
ich höre auch wieder in eine tastatur
tippt man hört so wie du tipps und merke
ich gar nicht reden
du kannst doch reden
ich hab gehört dass explosionen live
hacks ja er habe ich wilson haben ja ich
habe selber ganz okay dann sag mal hast
du musst ihn vermutlich suchen da muss
doch wirklich in dieser reihe
funktionieren werden wenn du schon mal
bei bisher auf twitter und geben auf
jeden fall dass dafür die beste live act
ich je gehört habe gibt's denn auch ein
live act für den shop oder irgendwie so
jetzt musst du gehen musst du angehenden
www.yourchance.de du diesen job machst
musst du alles aus wären alles kaufen
immer schöner instagram und leuten
empfehlen und das kommt sehr gut als
fluggerät und oberst ich kann der
nächste punkt steve st wir machen ganz
einfach fertig okay ich werde auch das
angebot zurückkommen
bei dieses bisschen näher nebelig wie
lange steuerfuss thomas selber
nachdenken über dandong frage so langsam
wie alt seid ihr 13 ja- und zwei jahre
älter als ich meinen dunkeln
[Musik]
hey nein ich dachte ich nicht ehrlich
hätte nicht gedacht dass ich dich hier
heute treffe das ist mega krass grad für
mich was darf ich ein foto mit dir
machen alter freuen wenn die baumängel
getroffen hat wie ja die heißt auch ins
haben das ist dich verlinken kann 0 5372
laser luca ok alles klar
instagram hallo
[Musik]
das ist aber ein hund wieso heißt der
untertitel aus wie in die ach so was ich
habe auch im moment ich hole immer kurz
2000 jahre später dass mein hund
ihr habt den besten job der welt offen
[Musik]
ihr seit dem heutigen video immer geil
solche unterhaltung hier zu haben
hey ho mein gott dass ich zu einem
treffen muss elf hatte gestern noch 39
grad fieber aber jetzt bin ich schon
wieder cooler unterwegs danke das freut
mich dass es sich freut
1000 euro bitte was geht bei dir was
machst du gerade
ich würde auch gerne freunde warten aber
ich habe leider keine aber wir sind bei
so vielen menschen nacht verbindung ist
auf jeden fall superdome in unserem kopf
eine ewigkeit später
escape taste
das wollte ich wollte
immer mal sehen heimweh live um ein gott
schöner rudi auch den oder gerade anhalt
wo gott freundlich doch wir haben es mit
einer person zu tun die wieder kein
mikro hat sorry ich höre ich mache eine
spendenaktion demnächst wohl dass ihr
euch alle mikros kaufen könnt ich höre
ich atmen
[Musik]
ja ich dachte erst du hast kein mikro
und dann hätte ich auch immer so hätte
ich doch das sind große worte das war
ziel von video meine damen und herren
wenn es euch gefallen hat und ich
nächsten sonntag auch wieder eine folge
mit luca hochladen sondern lasst man
leichter und bei 50.000 likes
heute ist eine große zahl aber da werde
ich das machen das wasser ziehen
das war es jetzt hier vom video ihr
könnt jetzt hier meinen kanal abonnieren
oder hier unten mal einen schock aus
checken jetzt findet ihr zwei andere
videos und belgischen abonnenten zeit
könnt ihr auch die glocke klicken dann
willkommen die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]